merry christmas it's the best time of
year that's right it's secret santa time
every year we draw names from a hat
digitally and then we all have to give
presents to each other and then guess
who gave the present unbeknownst to us
one of us in this room is santa it will
be up to us to discover who that santa
is is it one of us is all of us this is
pretty simple somebody goes and gets a
present they open it up they laugh and
they cry a little bit at how touching
the contents are inside and they try to
guess which marvelous person gave that
present to them christian is a hip santa
here
what's up i'm handing out gifts this
[Music]
[Applause]
year open this
side
up
open that side up
[Music]
it's my boy
you got a villager you got a villager
it's one of his uh strong characters and
smash bros
[Music]
it's all
in an array
it's jerky
jerky for days someone someone clearly
knows that i eat way too much jerky this
is like a week of jerky
maybe a week
so clearly it's not jake
are you avoiding eye contact
[Laughter]
not me
all right reveal yourself
i am
i heard you were a big fan of beef jerky
so i made you a beef jerky fan that's
what that is
yeah it's beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh wait this is an animation cell oh
it's a nice animation cell too i mean
guess that this is a gift from sam
[Music]
you know i gotta be honest with you i
don't know what that's from
but we'll find out it i went through
every single one on the website and that
was the coolest one hey if you know what
anime this is from please comment below
all right
the queen
someone knows about my chessboard
oh there's another box inside of a box
inside of a box inside of a box
yeah son
texas mug
jordan
no
i don't know
grand reveal
i got you a cup
the reason this is decorated with the
queen's game
it's because i
two weeks ago i ordered this except they
shipped it from the uk and it just they
decided to take a long time doing it so
it's the queen's gambit
chess the board game
[Laughter]
one one board 52 cards
four gambits 32 chess tokens
i guess i guess you can technically play
chess with it
ridiculous
oh it's also a box
you're a good friend okay so if it's a
good friend that eliminates most
everyone here
okay who could this be
daniel
dang okay
christian
dang okay all right reveal
[Applause]
yourself man i've had
neck and shoulder issues this year it's
been a bit of a thing
[Music]
merry christmas thank you
oh
whoa
whoa holy crap
it's my jeep it's my one wheel it's my
dog calzone
me and seth rogen my
our lego and that's me and my pops
that's the street i grew up on holy crap
i'm gonna go with
jordan yeah wow
[Applause]
wow
i was hitting up your friends for like i
was like what how do you spell his
freaking middle name that's his middle
name oh my god you asked me yeah kawali
nahinah
means sweetest music of a gentle voice
you had a fear that's a brave truth of
the word that's my middle name
oh my gosh
oh
three times the caffeine of earl grey i
haven't been drinking tea because i've
been drinking coffee and you can't go
back to tea once to start on coffee
but
with all this caffeine i think i might
have a chance so that gives me hope for
the new year
oh my gosh there's a water filtration
system oh that's going in my camping box
okay
a light
500 lumens my emergency supply kit just
got way better thank you so much jonah
for this gift
thanks man thank you
oh snap
is it
garbage
what is this garbage there's literally
screws in here why is this two years in
a row two years in a row it's garbage
town
trash dude
what's in there
watch dc
[Music]
let me get some garbage out of the way
there's garbage
dude
old cables for a computer
[Music]
i was looking for that is it trash dude
is it did you get trash
tacos
i'm just great i'm happy i'm so happy
who did who did this
my first guess is
nico no
because that looked like a nico shoe i'm
gonna go for
dean
dean wood though no
santa you were mad i am the garbage
[Applause]
i just have to say this there is one
hidden piece of garbage that has a
secret oh
ready i gotta fight i gotta rummage
through the garbage now the taco shells
why don't you open that up open this up
so fun is this a printed picture of the
cover of a book that i want for dnd
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh this is so sweet
this is from spirit away
this is so beautiful
oh
this is some
beautiful teeth oh i've been meaning
some cool air and i already know it's
natalie yeah this is my dog
well i feel like i won
secret
it's got some good weight to it
we got an iron maiden
cassette tape
dude
[Music]
iron maiden on vinyl dude
this is a great record too
uh i'm gonna guess christian because you
knew it was the new record
[Music]
iron maiden
thank you dude yes how did you know i
like iron maiden so much when i pulled
your hat i hit up your girlfriend oh
that was a smart move
okay
who this is
a girthy present thank you whoever
oh okay well so
it's it has red wren's signature at the
bottom
[Applause]
it's been a huge pleasure working with
you this year your talent both behind
the camera and in post help elevate what
we did together to something greater
than it could have been otherwise
and i'm forever grateful for your help
but i will i'm gonna it's so heavy what
the hell is in this
whoa
[Applause]
whoa son you can put it on your kitchen
table it works inside outside makes like
a little like six seven inch flame lasts
about three hours and if you mix that
gel with gasoline you can make a flame
thrower
ideas
[Applause]
all right first of all whoever did the
jewels bless you
this is so pretty now
oh this is cool
it's from the office
wait is that an actual like
thing from the office there must be like
another one that's coming or something
because it says temp right temporary
right am i crazy
oh you don't watch the show do you come
on peter
how dare you think that
what is up with you
in case of emergency break glass
what what
[Music]
look at what's inside of it
[Applause]
there's a nice print in the mail it's
coming oh that's about it
[Applause]
[Music]
that's a throw blanket
that's exia
one more thing
oh
it's a rx 78-2 mugs
[Applause]
crazy is it christian
reveal yourself
it's from chase but chase couldn't make
it out today
thank you so much chase this is great
sack bro
okay so i have oh my gosh so many
bandanas which is great
because i use them instead of masks
which is fantastic no you didn't
this is hard to get
this
metroid dread game of the year okay
fantastic so we got some pug socks
fantastic
this one says oh boy
[Music]
no
way
oh man ah this is beautiful
[Music]
i wish it was that's a really good
i got my elves up there
[Music]
oh come on now y'all
some fuzzy slips
from a cold toes everyone knows you have
cold toes
griffin come on down
come on down you dirty dog
come on down thank you my friend
i appreciate you man thank you griffin
asked me my shoe size last week
so that was the giveaway thank you very
much
i love the wrap draw first of all
that's a filter right
yeah it's some sort of uh is it like a
diet diopter
wait let me open this thing and see if
it's connected
oh
this is like from inception this is the
uh
so i feel like they're connected you
spin it on the screen yeah i spin it on
the thing and then i know that this
world isn't real
wait it actually is going to be sending
you a message you're asleep to wake up
who did this to me
thank you
and it's still spinning thanks man i
really appreciate it just met you i know
you got a fresh desk and uh you know if
you want to escape reality for a few
minutes yeah
thank you santa
wow
awesome
it's an erin yeager non-scale full
action plastic funnel kit but it's not
sealed
oh
oh no
that's awesome hell yeah i love working
with my hands it's very meditative and i
know who this is
wait wait there's a cartoon
regardless of how dark the story can get
it's about perseverance it's about not
giving up in the face of adversity no
matter what happens
keep moving forward
and your buddy gets
conked in the leg and he's like
what do you do you walk over
you
smack his ass
[Music]
[Applause]
very skeptical
what was that who
he found your gift what the heck
[Music]
my car is only so big dude
i only have so much trunk space
what the heck is this
man i know what this is
get this freaking trash
of course
oh yeah
boys
[Music]
do i have to go in there
don't you close this on me don't you
close this
hold on
my gifts aren't here yet
we'll start with that
this was printed out
today this morning what's today is today
the 10th yeah this morning
at 11 16 a.m
titled christmas.png
[Laughter]
ornaments red jingle bells
spread cheer your gifts are not here
okay
it looks like i got a pair of
this freaking goofball
i got a pair of belay glasses which are
very great when you're rock climbing
thank you i needed a pair whoever got
them for me slugger have you given out a
gift yet slogger is this from you
hey oh thank you does he get to keep the
garbage bin
no i actually need it did you bring that
all the way from your house
i
shoved that in my car it was really
difficult
you put that in your car it barely fit
favorite moments of 2021 some of my
favorite moments a lot has happened this
year every day something fun happens
around here i mean obviously number one
freaking
mark hamill dude
we were doing the luke skywalker video
and i was like trying to be chill about
it but i was like you guys need a person
for the face
yeah just by complete happenstance i get
would be the person with the deep fake
and then i will always have this message
from mark hamill bravo oh
that's for you that's directly to you
mark type hi dean
responding to you directly
so i'm gonna give that to you for a
frame he's crying he's crying
wren you
walking out in the wedding dress that i
just didn't anticipate you to be wearing
a wedding dress for that ai video um
that was uh above and beyond what i
expected you to do for it but you always
go for it and i always appreciate that
about you i had a really amazing time
doing the to the death production and
being able to act in that nico was great
working with you on that was great work
with youtube thank you
my favorite moment of 2021
was vfx artists react to saaho it's
quite possibly the funniest most chaotic
piece of copyright infringement i've
ever seen
uh and second favorite is uh everybody
getting together that friday and
watching soho
[Applause]
going up to that ghost town was a blast
and just uh i love going on adventures
like that and then also
having my pops on the couch that was
that was just like a full circle thing
because he got me interested in movies
and vfx and then you know now we get to
do that for a lot of people and to have
him on was just like it made sense so
that was cool that was very cool a
couple
obviously super cool moments was getting
to hang out with
seth rogen and adam savage obviously a
highlight of my year seth rogen and adam
were definitely huge ones for me it was
a very legitimizing moment for
everything that we're doing i mean i
know we've legitimized ourselves in many
ways but that was really cool and more
or less like marks a milestone
at least for me personally but you know
for all of us too since i was a teenager
i was the fan of the mythbusters
and adam savage himself got me really
into prop making and handing him
something that i made and her his first
question wasn't anything but
does it work
and i had the ability to answer
yes the horn works and then his first
response was to blow the horn that i
made that that's i can die now i met
adam savage and he blew my horn
two go-to's
filming son of a dungeon and releasing
son of a dungeon easy go-to's son of a
dungeon getting to draw
like all the time for six months or so
was like a childhood dream um it was one
of the coolest things i've ever gotten
to do i had nothing to do with son of a
dungeon but watching son of a dungeon as
an outsider not having anything to do
with it that was freaking awesome and i
just had a smile on my face the whole
time you're freaking like you're a rope
toss i mean dying dude that was like the
freaking rope toss well we passed 25 000
subscribers on the website um
i i told nico it wasn't going to happen
but it happened anyway
starting my work here with you all
[Applause]
not to steal jordan's is definitely uh
coming to corridor for sure i was one of
those people who like watched corridor
for a really long time so it honestly is
this is perfect because it's uncanny i
might be dreaming i don't know yet even
though i i left earlier this year you
all have been
the best to bring me back constantly and
have me be a part of this amazing family
it really is a family and i still have
so much to learn from everybody here
yeah you can learn how to play smash
bros i couldn't play smash bros i can
learn how to play smash bros that is
very true
playing smash brothers
at this tv is like so so many
shenanigans like some of the times i've
laughed the hardest have been at that tv
oh wait i know what the second one is
but the video for it's not out yet so i
don't know if i can say it
but if you head over to youtube.com node
you can check out our 2021 smash tourney
watch as old rivalries are reignited and
new contenders make a bid for the crown
i really realized it this week
that
you suck at smash bros
oh man it was like this whole year was
so awesome and it was a pleasure working
with you guys this is just an insane
group it's like baffles me every day i'm
going to work you know there's a point
in time there's a day
i'm sitting on the couch just in the
main room upstairs everybody's just
working quietly
and i just took a moment i looked around
and just watched everybody work for a
moment and just
appreciated the fact that
somehow we've ended up in a situation
where all just working on really cool
projects together for people that are
passionate about seeing the stuff that
we make
and
i kind of bookmarked that moment in my
mind as a
just as they like you know
take this this is great appreciate it
save it forever this uh the second
family of mine it's a really beautiful
experience and i love you guys love you
guys i love you all
[Applause]
so many good moments
i had like everything was a great time
this year
oh yeah that was a cop-out
you know all these memories that you're
hearing us say wouldn't be possible if
you guys weren't watching thank you for
enabling us to make this stuff thank you
for being into what we make
and yeah just thank you for supporting
us see you guys in secret santa 2022.
merry christmas happy holidays all that
stuff happy new years consider
subscribing
[Applause]
oh
wow
[Applause]